this green sea turtle is providing free  transportation to a few hitchhikers the  turtle was seen swimming with these  passengers off the coast of dahab egypt  [Music]  sea turtles often have organisms that  attach themselves to their shell some  are in fact parasitic while others are  commensal posing no threat to the turtle  crabs barnacles shrimp oysters algae and  other life-forms have all been seen on  the Turtles  the non parasitic organisms mainly used  the turtle as a form of transportation  green sea turtles have amazingly long  lifespans often reaching 80 or more  years  sadly green turtles are listed as an  endangered species they are killed for  their meat and eggs  loss of habitat boating accidents and  fishing nets also contribute to a  declining number of the species  [Music]  [Music]